just like everybody else in this world
I've been enjoying immensely
um the 10 part documentary every Sunday
night we're seeing two at a time two
incredible hours called the last dance
on ESPN and the director of this
incredible product is on the Rich Eisen
show right now Jason hare how are you
Jason I'm great man how are you Congrats
on this in advance of our conversation
here just amazing
well done it's so great thanks very much
we're still we're still not done with
the series we're still working every day
on finishing the final episodes but it's
great to see the positive response so
far no kidding so you're still you're
still working you're in edit Bay's etc
remotely or however you're doing this
for for the final well how many episodes
are you still working on right now we're
down to the last three right now we're
about first and goal from the one inch
line on the on episode 8 and then we
have 9 and 10 we finished our final edit
for episode 10 on Friday at around
midnight so that was the end of a
two-year process of all the pictures
locked
and now it's a three week process too
because this goes out to 185 countries
so they have to subtitle it and I have
to close caption it and then there's
sound design and an audio mix and then
color correction so all kinds of just
kind of sweeping up details kind of like
the extra point avatar touched down but
we still have some work but the hard
part is over well I appreciate the
football analogies right here Jason all
that said when did you get the call and
from whom to say hey I know this is
we're talking June but we'd like to move
this up because everybody is in need of
a distraction right now with what's
going on in the real world what did you
get that call pretty pretty immediate
after the shutdown went into effect
which i think was that right after the
Gobert game we all kind of looked at
each other I think that was March 11th
and then that following Monday was the
16th I think that by that Wednesday we
were all talking ESPN Netflix and the
NBA and the Jordan Brand and my team
were all talking internally about can we
do this and then we had a call that week
and everyone said let's go for it we can
we can get these on the air because the
first two or three were done by that
point so we had to dis back time out
when are we going to have 10 done which
is about May 15th so we said all right
do we want to do ten weeks in a row with
one episode do we want to do two
straight weeks with all 10 episodes
leading up to May 17th it was a lot of
permutations but I think they hit the
right one with with five weeks in a row
with two per week
Jason hare the director of the last
dance joining me here on the Rich Eisen
show somebody from questions to ask you
but I think I'm gonna go for the most
important one is how did you gain
Jordans trust he's so relaxed he's got I
guess what his own personal tequila he's
like a fist in is what it looks like
next to him just just a couple inches
shy of a tumbler with his cigar and he's
so comfortable how did you gain his
trust Jason well his his team had the
foresight to put me in front of him a
few times in the lead-up to when we
began shooting so I met him in September
of 17 this project was brought to me in
July of 16 and we were in negotiations
and all that for for all these partners
to come together for well over a year I
actually had time to go off and make the
Andre the Giant documentary for HBO
while they were still at the table
discussing high-level stuff who would
air it and all kinds of stuff and I'm
not involved in it by the time I got out
of Andre they were still negotiating and
wrapping up those negotiations and we
were ready to go but I had never met
Michael at that point so they put me in
front of him three or four times within
like an eight or nine month period just
to hang out nothing like nothing
high-level just relaxed because I think
he abhors meetings he'd rather just like
chill out with you and have a beer and
and and talk a little bit and get to
know you so we did that a few times
about a time we sat down for that first
interview he already knew me it's not
like he knows me well to this day that
were always spent you know a number of
hours together but I think he knew what
my vision for the project was and I
think that he knew that he was in a safe
space where I wasn't gonna you know we
tackle some subjects in this thing that
people want us to tackle but it's not
done on the salacious way and it's not
done a gratuitous way so I think that he
felt comfortable that he had the right
person telling the story and hopefully
that's that's the comfort that you see
exhibited by him yeah and in terms of
what you're going to tackle in in future
episodes I want to put a pin in that but
I want to get into some of the stuff
that you you've already hit
it you know Jordan said coming into this
that he was expecting not to come out
smelling like a rose but it sure looks
like Jerry Krause is the is the
antagonist here Jason what what what
what's your take on on Krauss's role in
all this and where Reinsdorf sits
because he Ron's darfs got that
beautiful suit on but all I remember
back when I was sitting on the Sports
Center set was wondering why would Ron's
Dorf let Krauss do whatever the heck he
damn pleased when he could step in and
change the dynamic with a snap of his
fingers he could he was running the
White Sox and still is you know owner of
the White Sox and the Bulls and I think
that that grinds offers from a
generation before the owners that we
know the Jared Joneses and the Mark
Cuban's who were sitting on the bench
and standing on the sidelines and are
very involved in personnel decisions and
and things of that sort
Reinsdorf was old school and he hired he
hired Jerry Krause because they shared
the same philosophy and he trusted
Krause's decisions as he said in episode
one I didn't hire someone to win a
personality contest so I think that he
was more content to to delegate than to
dive in deep he actually had to he
negotiated Michael's final couple of
deals which those are the ones that were
referred and 33 million apiece he did
those directly with Davis Falken and he
was the one who flew up to see Phil in
the summer before that final season in
the summer of 1997 but I think he
trusted Jarrett immensely and you know
what Jerry earned that trust because all
of those titles the only piece that was
in place when Jerry arrived was Michael
Jordan who become a year before
everything else Jerry was the architect
of those teams so it's a little bit
disappointing when I hear and it's it's
totally not the fault of the audience
because it does far if you had the
ticket villain it's Jerry Krause he
looks like a cartoon going to begin with
he just he just he checks up all the
boxes and it's easy to blame him but a
lot of people wanted credit for the
success of those teams I think David
Halberstam said it best when he said
that Jerry deserved more credit than he
got but he wanted more credits and he
deserved and that that had sits right on
the head Jerry always just wanted to be
one of the guys he never was one from
the time he was a kid he was never one
of the guys and now
he's hanging out with the ultimate cool
kids on the planet and he's thinking I
put you guys all in place I'm your boss
so I deserve to be on this bus I deserve
to be hanging out with you and cracking
jokes and he just never was going to be
that so I think by the end of the series
we did try to give Jerry is do and
you're going to see some people offer
some superlatives about Jerry that you
would not expect at this point in the
series the people who are speaking up on
his behalf towards the towards the end
of episode 10 are going to be surprising
to people but I just wish that I could
have interviewed Jerry myself because I
had so many questions for him and I
would love to have gotten his take you
know so many people with time I think
that that they're more honest one of
Michael's concerns at the outset of this
thing was that people with this much
time in in hindsight would give their
own version of the events that it
wouldn't be accurate and I was always at
the opinion that if anything people are
going to be more accurate cuz they're
willing to be more honest because
there's less at stake a lot of these
guys you know only involved in the
league involved in the league remotely
whereas even 10 years ago they had more
of a role with their teams and things
like that so it's been really great to
see that these guys sat down and opened
up and they were candid and they were
generous with their opinions and their
emotions so hopefully Jerry Jerry's
character will get rounded out a little
bit as the series goes on but I think
that there's no doubt that he was at the
very least the architect of those teams
have put the pieces in place for one of
the greatest dynasties ever he passed
away at the age of 77 in 2017 and he was
inducted into the Basketball Hall of
Fame that year posthumously
Jason hare the director of the last
dance here on the Rich Eisen show how
much of a conversation do you have with
the ESPN about allowing no bleeps and
let everything work blue like you like
you have it's been dynamite heroes so
really never would have had the temerity
to even to even offer that up because
III definitely thought that would have
gotten shut down you know I thought we
were lucky to get a cigar on TV with
some of the rules there in place
especially with a Disney Company but
credit John Donne Libby Geist and Connor
shell and and all the way up to Jerry
potaro and even Bob Iger
had had a say in this thing and all of
them were adamant that this story should
be told the way that
was meant to be told in the way that the
characters tell it so I was thrilled I
never like I said would have thought I
was hoping they would give us you know
even at HBO we had there was a list of
like you could have three f words per
half-hour and you couldn't have anything
if someone was saying something you know
that was explicit it had to be referring
just to like genitalia or something it
couldn't because in all kinds of lists
this was just like alright the rough
one's gonna be on ESPN and the the kids
for any one's going to be an ESPN 2 and
that's it so I was thrilled it's amazing
I mean just hearing the raw emotion of
Ron Harper talking about not guardian of
Jordan was amazing and then you know
Horace Grant what he called the Pistons
straight up last night because they
didn't shake their hands and Jordan's
reactions in the way he's I think it's
amazing Jason and I do credit everybody
to let the because it just does
I understand it's it's working blue and
the language is is not safe for work but
it does lend a certain sort of rawness
to the emotion that we need to hear that
said what what Rodman's story at the
cutting room floor Jason there had to be
one or two or five about last night
nothing explicit I would have loved to
ago gone more into because I think it's
easier to paint - as a caricature you
know he's got these he's got the the
tattoos and the piercings and all that
but I've always been there the opinion
that all that stuff is armor and that
there's a there's a much softer guy
inside and we had so many stories about
what a gentle guy this guy was even when
he came to the Bulls his first day of
training camp in 95 96 no one wanted to
talk to him he was just off shooting by
himself in the corner and Bill
Weddington came in and and said why is
no one talking to Dennis and he also we
know to say to him and Bill and Dennis
shared an agent he came over and said
hey how you doing
I mean Dennis is an introvert and I know
it's not clear when you show him in
Vegas and he's surrounded by women and
and cigar smoke and and he's doing the
kamikaze shots but he is at heart and
introvert and this is a guy who was
looking for a father his entire life
never had one and he found one in Chuck
Daly and he found one in Phil Jackson
and they found an authoritarian an
authoritative figure in Michael he just
wanted structure this guy that's it and
he wanted to be wanted he wanted to be
loved I think Dennis's are deep down a
really needy guy he wants attention
because he wants people to love him and
some way so I wish we could have dope
dives a little bit deeper into that but
as ridiculous as it sounds 10 hours
isn't enough time to to tell all the
stories that we had to tell so we had to
just scratch the surface on that and I
know you got to go in about a minute so
just some quick hitters how deep do you
get into Jordans baseball tenure and why
he quit and what the the the rumors
about all that are do you hit do you had
any of that deep deep we got into
everything I mean the Michael's credit
there was nothing that was lost limits
and we interviewed David Stern
extensively about it we interviewed Rod
Thorn and Brian MacIntyre all the people
who made the decisions that that would
have been made if he if he were this if
the secret suspension occurred you know
my brother Paul is a lawyer down in
Miami and I consulted him for exactly
how to ask these questions of David
Stern because there's no I'm more savvy
and more fun to interview and spar with
and David Stern and and he's just been
you know a hero of mine forever for his
intelligence and his in his work ethic
and what he did with the league so we
had the perfect wording that that he
would have to answer it if he answered
these things and they were truthful and
it would put all these rumors to rest so
we spend a couple of episodes on the Ark
of Michael leaving why he left the
rumors about why he left the truth about
whether or not those rumors are true and
then his return episode seven and eight
May 10th that's when you can get all
that so are you saying you were more
nervous interviewing David Stern than
either President Clinton or Obama is
what you're saying apples apples
nervousness and orange nervousness but I
wasn't trying to get definitive legal
statements that Obama in Clinton and
then the last question that is the most
important question Chris Brockman you
have that I know you want to ask this
yes of course are we gonna see rich with
hair in any of these episodes Jason yes
yes we are
it's luscious and flowing and no special
effects needed man it just jumps off the
script a reason why we you don't have
many of those is because Stewart always
demanded the Jordan stuff I never really
got a word in edgewise when it came to
Jordan Jason s I think his face appears
and then a few times and Michael as you
know as a UNC guys a huge fan of Stewart
he's sorely missed but it's great to
feel his presence in this thing as I'm
sure he'd be thrilled to be a part of it
too
Jason Congrats you're being pulled in
many different directions I appreciate
you being allowed to be pulled into this
one this is dynamite can't wait for the
next six thanks so much for having me
right you got it that's Jason hare the
director the last dance
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here